[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein grundrezept ein basic
und zwar werde ich es machen das sind
diese kleinen teiglinge die werden aus
kartoffeln hergestellt kennt man auch
oft aus der italienischen küche und die
gibt es fertig zu kaufen im kühlregal
aber heute zeige ich euch wie ihr sie
aus einfachen zutaten ganz schnell auch
zu hause machen könnt ich zeige euch
hier mal die zutaten für den yuppies
brauche ich 500 gramm mehlig kochende
kartoffeln etwa 125 gramm mehl 2 eigenen
teelöffel salz einer prise muskatnuss
und pfeffer die kartoffeln habe ich
bereits vorgegart und zwar im backofen
so verlieren sie nämlich ihre
flüssigkeit und es ist auch besser damit
ich später im juni steigt einfach nicht
so viel mehr benötige ich habe sie dafür
mit einer gabel mehrmals eingestochen
und dann auf ein backblech gesetzt und
unten im backofen habe ich eine folie
eingelegt damit falls was runter tropft
einfach der backofen jetzt nicht
schmutzig wird und so habe ich sie dann
im ofen bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
etwa eine stunde gedauert und jetzt sind
sie noch schön lauwarm und jetzt kann
ich sie weiter verarbeiten
die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt schön
geschält und jetzt werde ich sie fein
reiben
ihr könnt sie aber zum beispiel auch
durch eine kartoffelpresse geben oder
auch durch in der spitzel presse
[Musik]
habe ich hier die kartoffelmasse und
gibt die restlichen zutaten dazu und
zwar erstmals salz dann muss card für
den geschmack etwas pfeffer zweige jetzt
nämlich nur so viel mehl das eine schöne
feste konsistenz entsteht und die masse
eben auch nicht zu feucht ist und jetzt
einfach nicht zu lange kneten die soll
nicht kompakt sein sondern eher luftig
und locker und ja ich hoffe ich kann man
hier schon sagen und ich merkte teig ist
jetzt einfach von der konsistenz her so
wenig ihn zusammen drücke bleibt so
zusammen und so ist nicht perfekt ich
habe ich noch mehr übrig und es kommt
einfach darauf an wie viel flüssigkeit
in dem eine kartoffel noch sind und
dementsprechend dem de mail
jetzt werden den yuppies geformt dafür
teile ich den teilabriss in vier
portionen 1 und formt daraus eine lange
rolle der jetzt etwa zwei zentimeter
durchmesser
jetzt kann ich hier die einzelnen yogis
abstechen
wer es jetzt richtig schön haben möchte
kann auch die ecken so ein bisschen
abrunden
so kennt man sie ja als fertigprodukt
man können dass sie mit einer gabel so
ein bisschen formen und die ganz
praktischen machen einfach nur so mit
der gabel dann sind sie ein bisschen
eckiger aber es geht auch schneller die
nockis könnt ihr auch direkt mit spinat
oder rekorder oder auch zum beispiel
roter beete oder kürbis zu bereiten
dann habt ihr nämlich auch direkt
gefärbte und bereits aromatisierten okay
ist jetzt sind die nockis alle fertig
und so viel arbeit ist es auch gar nicht
und jetzt werden sie so wie sie sind
einfach im salzwasser gegart dafür gibt
es hier in kochendes salzwasser rein und
dann sinken sie erst einmal auf den
boden und dann kommen sie nach oben und
sind dann auch gar es dauerte etwa zwei
bis drei minuten und ihr könnt da auch
gern die doppel drei oder vierfache
menge machen und sie auch ganz gut
einfrieren und da empfehle ich euch die
so auf einen torten retter zu legen mit
backpapier oder back poliert darauf man
können dass sie so erstmal ein bisschen
anfrieren damit sie eben nicht
aneinander kleben und dann können sie
nämlich in eine box verpacken und
wirklich bis zu zwei monaten auch im
gefrierfach lagern und auch die sind ja
es kann man jetzt wunderbare gerichte
zaubern ihr könnt sie als suppeneinlage
verwenden ihr könnt diese soße dazu
machen tomatensoße zum beispiel oder
auch einfach ein bisschen gemüse damit
anbraten
oder sie auch ganz einfach in butter
schwenken mit kräutern verfeinern und so
auf essen eine süße variante gibt es
auch aber ich denke ihr habt da ganz
viele eigene ideen ein paar rezepte
folgen bei mir auf dem kanal
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen mit diesem basic rezept und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
biss dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]